danny green
love d what a play
showtime
[Applause]
you see right
[Applause]
he's being unselfish right away he gets
the basketball the big man needs to run
ibiza zoo blocker goes and oh my
goodness baptized
mr collins sexton
[Music]
white all the lakers
[Applause]
lebron look at danny coming from the
side up up and bam
look at dwight i thought he stepped
inside the line i didn't think it was
close
i agree danny green lets it go off the
mark
and caruso there's the miss you see
monte's going in trying to help out on
the big and
forgets about caruso just a perfect
bounce for him
and beverly comes away with rebound
number four clippers looking for the
lead
george to the rack reverse
[Applause]
bossy's willing to give it up he changes
gears paul george and finishes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
does he have one more trick up his
sleeve
[Applause]
the runner is good he just
continues to exploit the mismatch it's a
foot speed race
and lou williams is going to turn the
corner every single time against julius
randle
with this lineup they're just showing
blue will a lot of
respect and everybody else they're
zoning up blocked by montrez warfare at
the rim
ciacom's coming down but how about this
blocked shot right here by montrez
tough matchup with a point guard this is
just big time effort
play right here for montreal
danny green what a play
showtime a good view danny green throws
it up there
there's the cup there's the guy there
but anthony davis
over the top of baines and just flushes
it
3 20 to play
[Applause]
kauai aggressive
and brad's going to call timeout but
let's go back why
leonard rising up on daniel teice
what a play from kwai leonard
take another look yeah he just died mess
around with the basketball just puts the
ball on the floor
goes hard to the basket
from downtown here
the crowd wasn't
quite as noisy there as it was here i'll
tell you
[Applause]
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleach report